look at that Rhonda Santa says he
wouldn't be Trump's running mate I'm not
a number two guy can be though and then
you'd be the number one guy and then it
was uh Trump's campaign said he's not
anybody's guy I think that was Stephen
Chung who said that so yeah I mean that
look the the argument is Donald Trump
did like a c-plus job in a lot of areas
in his first term he didn't drain the
swamp he fired some people he hired some
really bad people but foreign policy
wise I think Trump did a very very good
job especially with the Abraham Accords
uh with trying to get our troops out of
Syria crushing Isis those things are
really great and then the argument now
is if we're looking at these two guys
Rhonda says and Donald Trump
there's one thing that I care about the
most I think foreign policy Wise It's
hard to know for sure Ronda Sanders has
some experience in foreign policy Donald
Trump has good foreign policy not
perfect foreign policy but better than
Obama better than Biden better than
whatever the Democrats have to offer the
question I have is who is more likely to
fire people
Donald Trump even if it's only by one
percent because he wants revenge and the
shift which has become obvious to me is
that when asked about the greatest
threat the country faces Trump said it's
not China which is a market shift from
where he was in his first and second
campaigns he said it's within this
country referring to bureaucrats working
for government who can't be fired so one
of the things Trump did near the end of
his term which he which was reversed by
the Democrats by Joe Biden was the
schedule F attempt you can't just fire
federal employees they're protected it's
very difficult so Trump was trying to
strip away at those protections to try
and start getting some of these people
fired I think Rhonda Santos because for
a few reasons it'll be his first term if
he does get elected and he is being
backed by some prominent establishment
figures is more likely to say let's
negotiate and figure out how we don't go
to war with each other I won't go around
firing and destroying everything but you
guys let me get some of these policies
through Donald Trump is more likely to
go and say I will fire everyone I will I
will nuke all of these bureaucrats and
agencies I would rather Donald Trump go
in and fire and clean house and then
four years from now be it DeSantis or
whoever else from Swami or you know
maybe some other libertarian I have no
idea someone can then come in without
these bureaucratic permanent government
individuals who have been in government
for 30 years without without being
elected those people have to be fired
the problem ask a question why didn't he
do it the first time Trump was trying to
negotiate it was a it was it sounds like
an excuse what does that mean give me an
argument I'm just saying like you know
there's always a reason why there's an
excuse for why Trump wasn't able to do
something in his first term it's
literally the explanation of what Trump
was doing Trump talked to Sheldon
adelstein he gets these big donors and
they're like listen we're going to let
you do your thing but you got to play
ball with us and Trump says you got it
boss and then what ends up happening
John Bolton garbage that's what Rhonda
Sanders is doing right now with Ken
Griffin so my argument is Donald Trump
made a big mistake with these morons
that Rhonda Santa is doing right now
Trump is pissed off they screwed him
over and stabbed him in the back and is
more likely even if it is only two
percent to go in and try to fire these
people and just gut them from the system
whereas I see the Santos once again
meeting with big neocon donors and
playing the game that that Trump was
playing first time around
Trump was funded by big Pharma I mean
they donated to his campaign you know so
it's like I I don't know you're making
my argument that's my point right so I
don't know who these establishment
people are there
okay
you know everybody says that that uh
that um sorry DeSantis is endorsed by
you know Paul Ryan and he's Jeb Bush 2.0
and all this stuff and I see absolutely
zero evidence when really well the Jeb
Bush thing is dumb I mean the whole
thing is absolutely stupid Trump
endorsed Paul Ryan Trump endorsed John
McCain I mean yes I I don't understand
how they can use it that was tax again
eight years ago okay I think Paul was
bad and I did not vote for Trump in
2016. good I mean and so now and that's
the thing I wanna I wanna stress for
people that don't know who I am or don't
know my position I am a two-time trump
voter I voted for him in 2016. I voted
for him in 2020 even though I was off
the Trump train uh you know into the in
the covet years because he subsidized
the presidency to fauci and um you do
sound like a two-timer trump voter I was
you just said something I fully agree
with I was I was Hardcore too I ran I
was making up two timers
are going in fire change your support
giving you a hard time I understand who
would he replace them with is my concern
because he did not make good personal
choices if he went in and were to fire a
bunch of people who would he replace
them with Trump yeah I don't I don't
have faith in him I think that he failed
in his first term by giving the country
away to the medical industry in the in
the last year commissioner and that's
another conversation completely his
family what are you doing giving your
family power bro I mean I voted for
Trump not Jared Kushner not fauci and
that's who I got I don't want nepotism
in the White House is disgusting I want
talented well-situated people that can
do their job really really well that may
not even know each other that's what I
want and I got a man that went on a
vaccine tour for the last year and a
half in office pushing an experimental
clot shot sorry I don't know if I can
say that on YouTube well it was
experimental it is experimental and to
this day one of my the biggest reasons
why I no longer support this man is
because to this day he goes and praises
the damn vaccine and operation War warp
speed takes credit for all of it says
it's the greatest thing that ever
happened to mankind I mean one of them
you know he's he said he saved 500
million people with it or sorry maybe
it's 100 million I don't want to get
whatever I'm just saying a gigantic
amount of amount of people which is not
true and he has yet to take
responsibility for any of the adverse
reactions he doesn't even acknowledge
them and I think that's absolutely
disgusting and I I cannot support him
and I understand that the argument is
Ron DeSantis pushed it early on too
right Ron DeSantis at least can
understand that that was wrong and has
moved past it is now fighting against it
you know so I I just like Trump is has
such a big ego that he cannot take
responsibility for anything he ever did
wrong he just continues to double down
and it's disgusting the issue I take
with this the first thing is I'll say is
our obligatory just talk to a doctor
about what is right for you and make
sure you find a good and trustworthy
doctor because they do exist I know I'm
literally going to one next week because
I got to get surgery or whatever but
here's here's where I'm at politically
especially when it comes to like RFK I
don't agree with him on a lot of the
stuff he said especially the eua stuff
on Ivermectin and vaccines I just
there's a lot of people who adamantly
believe things because they choose to
believe them and they think they're
right about everything whereas my
positions are typically alike unless I
see something to a great degree that
like provides confirmation
there's not much I can really say about
it so you know we've had several debates
on this show I've debated several
leftist individuals and they'll ask me a
direct question about something
political I'll be like don't know
literally I have no why don't you have a
position on this when it comes to the
vax stuff I don't know that's why I
always I'm just like I don't know talk
to a doctor what I can say is Donald
Trump refuses to back down from this as
one of his major campaign victories what
we do know is that there was a judge I
think it was in New York who ruled that
the vaccine does not prevent
transmission of the virus and then later
on you end up with a bunch of news
outlets claiming that was fake news this
was a judge recently what is it uh the
the judge who gagged the Biden campaign
on censorship is I believe the same
judge who said that the vaccine was not
preventing transmission like so the
vaccine was like yeah the conspiracy
theorists crazy but the media the media
is then said the inverse so my point is
basically like I see these conflicting
and contradictory stories and then I
wonder why it is that people choose to
take a stance on something that is it's
very difficult to understand instead of
just saying like you know what honestly
I don't know I I don't know how you can
draw a conclusion on this one I'll give
you an example RFK talking about
Ivermectin I really for the life of me
even after sitting with Joe Rogan have
never been able to figure out how anyone
justifies their stance on Ivermectin
what did he say about Ivermectin RFK
said that the reason Ivermectin was
never approved was because it would end
the emergency use authorization for the
vaccines which is just logically
inconsistent they granted the EU way to
monoclonal antibodies if it were true
that there were alternative treatments
like Ivermectin hydroxychloroquine they
literally could have just given it an
eua people then make a money argument I
think Alex and I was arguing this that
because Ivermectin is so cheap they
didn't want to give it an EU and I say
make that argument I'm not making that
argument I'm literally saying for RFK Jr
to come out and be like that's the
reason they didn't approve it is because
they wanted to sell vaccines and they
needed the eua I'm like that doesn't
make sense I hear this kind of stuff all
the time and no one ever gives me a
legitimate answer so we talk about the
studies pertaining to Ivermectin we talk
about the studies here's what I'll just
say here's what I want to say about the
vaccine for instance it's it's my
problem with the vaccine is nothing to
do with whether or not anyone thinks
it's good or bad I don't know I can only
tell you make sure you trust your doctor
and there's a good one and there are
some good ones out there they're not
super expensive you just gotta go to the
right places go to cities and you'll
find good doctors but the issue here is
government mandates of medication I'm
not going to see her make medical
arguments I have no idea Trump wants to
tout this as a major success Trump also
says the mandates were bad Rhonda
Sanders also says the mandates were bad
what am I supposed to argue how am I
supposed to have a conversation with
someone when they make a definitive
scientific statement on something that I
can read all these studies and I'm just
like well I have no I literally have no
idea I'm not a doctor well I can mention
just the news for instance reported
there's more data coming out about
people suffering from myocarditis which
is now confirmed for many of these
vaccines there are concerns around I
think one was Paul I think Johnson
Johnson may have been pulled But
ultimately like I am not making a Again
YouTube I'm making any widespread claims
about all the vaccines my point is there
is data coming out but even with this
there is still the simple statistical uh
argument that
if you give if you mandate 400 million
doses of a vaccine don't be surprised if
you get a thousand news stories about
Adverse Events that does not mean there
is a higher density of Adverse Events it
does however suggest to the libertarian
point the government should not be
mandating medications to people which is
where I'm at
blaming Donald Trump for what Democrat
Governors did does nothing to convince
me of why I should vote for Rhonda
Sanders I'm not that's not what I did at
all I'm saying that he has never backed
down he continues to praise operation
warp speed and rushing the vaccine just
a few days ago uh or like sorry I am so
bad with time like I don't know if it
was a week ago two weeks ago yesterday
that's just the present Epoch like
things move so quickly and so strangely
you never know
let me just say one thing let me just
say one thing uh you know he was just
again saying how great it was that he
was saying it usually takes the FDA
between 5 and 12 years or nine and 12
years to get this out but he got it out
in nine months that's what it was in
nine months isn't that I mean that's not
something to brag about my point is
that's kind of bad my point is stuff
should be tested longer this isn't I'll
tell you exactly what my thoughts are on
this I don't think you actually care
what do you mean it makes no sense for
you to say these things to me because
you never like I don't care yeah I don't
think you care at all really okay
because I think that my mom passed away
because of it well but but okay and that
and that I'm sorry to hear about your
mom I'm not trying to bring that into it
but like to say that I don't care about
what the vaccine what the vaccine is
doing to people I know people that were
injured after taking this vaccine what
do you mean I don't care this isn't just
a political Point against Trump this is
serious when has anyone ever talked
about the the efficacy of of of testing
criteria
okay but this was rushed into society
this was something that so if your
argument is authoritarianism and
government mandates I agree yeah if your
argument is the science was done wrong
I'm like when has anyone ever known
anything
rushing it and bragging that he rushed
it without proper testing is a problem
and he continues to praise it and double
down and say that he saved 100 million
people when that's not true thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time